Learn how to succeed as an engineering manager
in this course from Ankita Kulkarni.
Anyone can learn to be a good leader.
Ankita is an experienced engineering manager
and she has a bunch of great tips to share with you.
A lot of developers aren't sure
how to become a engineering leader
or to succeed as an engineering manager or a leader.
They continue to act like individual contributors
as they aren't sure how to manage.
And as a result, the people that report into them
or under the leadership suffer.
Now, just like we learned JavaScript, Angular, React
or any other upcoming technology,
just like that leadership is also a skill set
that you need to develop and learn.
No one is a born leader.
You need to learn how to become a good leader.
In this specific course, I wanted to cover a few things
and give you a plan and strategy
to become a successful engineering leader.
So we will cover things like what I wish I knew
before becoming an engineering manager,
how to become a great leader,
a engineering leadership roadmap,
what are some differences
between a software engineering manager and a technical lead.
And not just that, we will also cover
how to communicate as a developer,
which will also translate into leadership skills
and how to give and receive feedback
as a developer and a leader.
So I really hope you enjoy this course.
If you have any questions, just comment below
and let me know.
Are you a individual contributor
that is curious about engineering leadership
or you wanna know what it takes
to become a successful engineering manager?
As I reflected back in my career,
there were a few things that I kind of wish I knew
before I made the transition
to becoming an engineering manager.
So in this video, I'm going to cover it all.
So first of all, I wanna say
that I was quite happy with the move,
but I really want you to know all these things
so you can make the best decision for yourself.
So let's get started.
So the first thing that I experienced as a transition
from being a developer to an engineering manager
was that you do feel like an outsider to your very own team.
Now you have a lot more power, right?
Being a leader, you can basically decide
who you get to hire within the team, who gets promoted.
You know all the salaries of your team members.
So you're not going to look at your team
the same way as you did before.
So you start feeling like an outsider
to your very own team.
That is the first thing you will experience
as you make the transition, or at least I did.
Because you have a lot more control and power,
you are now in charge of making the decisions.
Your team is going to look up to you as a leader.
If they don't know what to do,
they are going to look up to you for that.
So that is a bit of a shift and a mindset shift
that you need to go through as you make the transition.
So the percentage of time that you will spend coding
will drastically and significantly reduce
as a engineering manager.
A lot of people have this misconception
that as you transition from being a developer
to an engineering manager, it is basically a promotion.
It is the same role, maybe with a little bit more
of people managing responsibilities.
Well, if you want to be a mediocre engineering manager,
then sure, you can do that,
but don't spend a lot of time coding.
Because again, you have a lot more responsibility
as an engineering manager.
The first goal should be to grow the people on your team,
make sure that they are set up for success,
make sure you are reviewing their performance,
giving constructive feedback, managing stakeholders,
doing roadmap planning for the future.
And there is lots more that you need to do
to make sure that you are setting up your team
for success as an engineering leader.
They are looking up to you for leadership.
So if you spend a lot of time coding behind the computer,
then you will necessarily will not have time
to focus on your other important responsibilities,
and this will not make you a successful engineering manager.
So you might be wondering, well, if I'm not gonna code,
then how am I called an engineering manager?
Will I not just be a manager then?
Well, here's the thing.
You still have a lot of technical expertise
that got you to where you were, right?
But when you take on an engineering manager position,
it's a completely different role.
You can still use your strengths from being a developer,
and you should definitely be involved
in knowing all the architectural decisions,
to making sure that your team has really good standards
technically, make sure there are good code review processes,
make sure that you understand
all the architectural decisions being made,
and your team is not just thinking
just for that specific module that you're working on,
but they're also thinking about the scalability as well,
right?
So your experience as a developer
is going to definitely help you
when you transition to become an engineering manager.
But again, what got you here will not necessarily get you
to where you wanna go
being a successful engineering manager.
So make sure that you keep this in mind as you transition.
So again, should you code?
Well, it totally depends on your team's responsibilities.
If you have everything else under control,
if you do wanna pick up a task here and there,
just to make sure you understand the code base
a little bit more,
you are able to give feedback to your team,
and you're not just a manager managing,
you also are involved,
and they feel that you are involved as well,
then you can definitely do that.
But again, make sure that the main focus of your position,
of your role is not to code.
It's all these other things,
including maybe a little bit of coding.
So again, make sure you don't spend a lot of time
doing that.
You will feel a therapist many times
as you deal with people.
So the people on your team are going to come to you
with all sorts of problems.
Their performance is not necessarily tied
to their day-to-day job,
but also what's going on personally,
what's going on outside of work as well.
So sometimes you might feel
like you know a lot more about them personally as well
in order to make sure you connect with them professionally.
And you don't necessarily need to do that,
but I guess being a good engineering manager,
you need to care about the people that you work for.
Well, you will feel like a therapist at times
because you will spend a lot of time talking
about their thoughts and feelings,
but it's also important that you start drawing boundaries
because people are going through maybe a lot of stuff.
So if they need to talk to someone professional
other than you,
then definitely advise them of that as well.
But you will feel at times that it's necessary
to talk to them,
not just about work stuff,
but also about personal stuff.
So make sure that you keep it all confidential
because they think of you as a leader and they trust you
and that's why they're sharing all this information with you.
So make sure that you do that.
For an example, there was a developer who I was managing
and they clearly were not giving their 100%.
And I personally felt I could see that they were not,
even though they were always on top of their performance,
in this specific case,
they were not necessarily doing that.
Their performance was not great anymore.
So I got really curious to just check in
and ask them what's impacting them.
And it turns out there was something personal going on.
Without getting into too many details,
I was able to navigate and guide them
in terms of how they can manage
their personal and professional life.
And I also asked them to maybe take a day off,
a personal day,
just to make sure that they take care of that
before they can focus on work.
The next day they came back
and they were able to really recharge
and really take the time off
and deal with whatever they had to deal with personally
to be able to show up at work and give their 100%.
So again, this is important that you have that empathy
and you treat people as humans
and not just resources when you are an engineering manager.
Being an engineering manager can be lonely at times.
Like I mentioned that you will not feel like
the same team member anymore
as you did before when you are an IC.
And as you become an engineering manager,
you cannot necessarily talk to the developers on your team
about the problems that are going on in the company
because as a leader,
you need to shield them from that.
You need to make sure that they feel comfortable
talking to you about things
and they feel like their position is in a good spot.
If you talk to them only about the problems that are there
or whatever is going on in your mind,
then they might not feel as confident about the team
and the company that they work at.
So make sure that you shield them of that,
but also find a support system for yourself
and other engineering leaders
that you can talk to about problems as well.
So maybe find a mentor, take care of your own mental health
and make sure that you have a good support system
so that you can talk about problems
or and come up with solutions as well.
The direct reports are also going to share something
personal and private with you
and you will not be able to share that with anyone else
and you need to keep it confidential, right?
Because that is their personal information.
There's a lot that you will keep to yourself
and which will also make engineering leadership
a little bit lonely, but it doesn't have to be.
You can find a support system, you can join a community,
you can talk to other people and their leaders
going through the same journey as you
so that you don't feel alone
because it can definitely feel lonely at times.
I was also socially exhausted being in a lot of meetings
as I transitioned from being a developer to a manager.
Now, I was booked in a lot of back-to-back meetings
because everyone wanted to get a piece of me,
everyone had to pick my brain on things
and I had to make a lot of decisions just to make sure
that my team is on the right path.
But it doesn't have to be,
you don't have to be socially exhausted.
So you need to start planning your week a little bit better,
kind of figure out what the focus of the week is,
what your priorities are of that week
and accordingly push the things that are not that important
to the next week and try to say no as well,
which we'll cover later in this specific video,
but you will be socially exhausted
as you will be in a lot more meetings than you did
being a developer.
As an engineering manager, you will shield the team
from unnecessary meetings,
but that also means you are going to accept
a lot more meetings because you wanna make sure
that you have things under control.
So you will be socially exhausted,
so make sure that you spend some time,
take some time in the morning or in the afternoon
and book some focus time for yourself in your calendar
that no one gets to book over
so that we can get some meet time
and are also able to get some work done as well.
But that is a reality.
You will feel socially exhausted at first
without proper systems in place.
You are going to find a bit difficult to say no at first.
Now, unless you were a leader before
and you are already good at that, then please ignore this.
But if you're not, then it is definitely going to be
a bit difficult for you to say no
because everyone would need a piece of your team.
They would all come to you for priorities,
their priorities that they need to work on,
and you need to figure out how you can
position those priorities along with current priorities
that your team is working on.
If you say yes a lot, your team is going to be burnt out.
So make sure that you don't say yes to everyone.
A strategy that I transitioned was,
instead of saying no, you can talk to them
about the priorities that you do have
and accordingly prioritize their stuff
maybe in the next quarter
or maybe a month from now and so on.
So you're not necessarily saying no,
you are saying not now, let's do this at this specific day.
So again, but you're going to have it
a bit of a difficult time initially to say no
and make sure that you know what your priorities are.
As you transition to being a manager,
you are going to manage a team
that will have different personalities.
So for example, some might be more extroverted
and will speak up a lot more
but others are not as extroverted
and they don't speak up
and maybe need an opportunity to do so.
So for example, extroverted folks are going to talk
as they think and they will keep talking.
Whereas introverted folks will need some time
to think first and then talk about anything.
So you really need to make sure that you're balancing
both personality types in a specific team
so that you're not just listening
to one specific personality type as you make decisions.
You need to balance it out to make sure
that you are asking questions
and making sure that you're including everyone
in the meeting, making sure that you have organized
the meeting in such a way that everyone can speak up
and give their thoughts.
Maybe you can ask someone about what they are thinking
and so on.
But again, you are going to deal
with a lot of different personality types.
So you need to make sure you need to balance them all.
Otherwise you're only going to lean onto the person
that is the loudest and you really don't want to do that
as an engineering manager.
You want to create a transparent culture
and where people are happier to work for you.
They are excited in the morning to come work for you
for the team and you are going to be a huge part of that.
That's why it's important for you to make sure
that you take this into account.
What got you here will not necessarily get you further.
As a developer, it's your job to make sure
that your skills are up to date, right?
So if it is a specific technology that you work in your team,
for example, React, how do you make sure
that the performance of the app is really good
or how do things work with server components
and so on, right?
Now, React is important as a developer
because that's the technology that your team is using.
But when you transition to be a manager,
you shouldn't be focusing on making sure
that you have up-to-date React skills.
You need to be focused on how can you be the best manager
that you can be?
And those skills are very different
than being a developer skills.
So make sure you're spending time
on the development of your skills as well,
such as how do you give constructive feedback?
How do you promote someone?
How do you do performance reviews and so on?
Sometimes you are going to disappoint people
because their promotion did not get accepted.
And even though you think that they deserve to get promoted,
you need to be in a position to put them forward
in the best possible way.
And those are skills that you need to learn
which you didn't necessarily knew about
when you were a developer.
So again, there are a lot more skills
that you need to learn being an engineering manager
that you won't necessarily know as a developer.
So make sure you keep learning
and figure out how others are doing it in the company.
Are there specific strategies and frameworks
that you can use to make sure
that you're giving feedback the right way?
Or if someone is causing any troubles in the team,
then make sure they are aware of that
without making them feel too bad about it.
There's so many things that you will deal with
as an engineering manager
that you didn't necessarily deal with before.
So make sure that you are on top of your personal skills
as well and your reading books, eBooks, and so on,
just to make sure that you have control of everything.
And again, this makes the journey fun for you as well
because you're not just stuck with the skills
that you transitioned with.
You also are always improving and growing
and experimenting with the team that you're working with
so that your team becomes a really high-performing team.
Unfortunately, not every day is going to be a good day
being a manager.
Sometimes you have to give really difficult feedback
to your team or a specific team member
and their response to that might be really emotional
because the feedback is really difficult.
And because of that, your day is going to be impacted.
You are going to spend hours talking to someone
just to make sure that they understand the impact
they're possibly having on the team.
And again, that can be very exhausting.
Sometimes you want to get someone promoted,
but their promotion is not going to get accepted
or they want more salary
and you are unable to get it approved for whatever reason.
You are going to have a bad day because of that
because it is going to be really emotional for you.
So being an engineering manager can be very difficult
because you are dealing with people
and people are humans, not just computers.
When you are a developer, you're writing code
and you're just dealing with computers,
you're obviously dealing with team dynamics
and communication and whatnot.
But being a manager, that is in the forefront.
That's why you really need to make sure
that you're digging care of your mental health
as you transition because it's not just
your team's mental health that's important,
it's also yours because if yours will start to get affected,
then the team is going to experience the same as well.
It's the same analogy that when you're in an airplane,
make sure that you're wearing an oxygen mask as well
before you give it to other people.
It's the same thing being a manager
that you are always in service of other people,
but make sure that you also take care of your mental health
and your personal needs as well.
And if you do need to take the time off,
then please do so because that will have an impact
on others too.
So again, make sure you take care of yourself.
What if you don't like being an engineering manager
and you want to go back to being a developer,
you really like coding and now you have to deal
with all these different things
that you don't necessarily want to deal with
or you had a misunderstanding of the position
and I want to say that if you do give it a shot,
let's say there's an opportunity available in your team
or in a company and you decided to go for it
and six months later or a year later, you are like,
you know what, I love being a manager,
but I love being a developer as well, so I want to go back.
It's completely okay for you to go back.
In fact, I would highly recommend it.
It's important to keep going back and forth
between being a manager and being a developer
so that you are really appreciative of both positions
because a lot of times when you're a developer,
you don't necessarily know what an engineering manager
has to go through
because they don't necessarily share everything with the team
because they're supposed to shield the team, right?
So being a manager and then switching to a developer,
you are going to build a lot more empathy as well,
but there's nothing wrong in switching back and forth.
In fact, it's totally recommended
because if you think about it,
in your career throughout your life,
if you want to stick to just being one position,
then it's probably not going to be as challenging
by switching back and forth,
you're learning a lot more skills
that will be helpful in either way.
So again, if you really want to switch, go for it,
but I would highly recommend you
to also give it a shot to see
if you really like being an engineering manager
and making sure that your skills are up to date
and you are always learning and growing
because as a developer, you do that,
so do the same when you transition to being a manager.
Well, I talked a lot about what it was like
when I transitioned from being a developer
to an engineering manager.
I know you might be wondering,
is it even worth it to become an engineering manager?
Well, I would say yes,
it's really rewarding seeing the growth of people
and the impact that you are going to have on folks.
I have worked with so many different people
and when I do give them feedback
or I provide suggestions and insights
based on my experience to help them grow,
it is awesome to see that they work on those
and they grow because of you as well.
So the impact is going to be huge on other people's career.
So again, being an engineering manager is really rewarding.
The other thing is you will have a lot more influence
and the impact is really growing to grow massively
in a company because your focus
is not just going to be your team,
but your impact is going to be really visible
across the org as well, right?
So being a developer, you only think about your team,
but being an engineering manager,
your influence and your impact is going to grow a lot more,
which won't necessarily be possible being a developer.
By being an engineering manager,
you get to control or have a say on the roadmap
on what your team gets to work on.
So based on the goals of the company,
you get to decide what's important for the team.
The problems that you will solve as an engineering manager
will be at a larger scale
and it won't be at a smaller scale anymore.
So again, you are going to be solving bigger problems
that are important for the company
for not just your one team, but several teams.
So your impact is going to be a lot more
if you take advantage of it, being a manager.
If teams are not working together,
you get to be the one to make sure
that they talk to each other.
They have the same common understanding.
You become the decision maker,
but also someone who comes and resolves problems.
And it sometimes is going to be hard
because misunderstandings can happen,
but as an engineering manager, you are the leader.
So they are going to look up to you
for solving all their problems.
And even though you don't necessarily need
to solve the problem on your own,
you can make sure that the teams get together
and talk it out and facilitate the meetings
so that problems get resolved.
So the problems that you'll be solving
won't just be your own problem
as you were when you were a developer,
but you get to control and you get to work
on a lot more problems because of it.
So I would say that being an engineering manager
is really rewarding.
If there is an opportunity in your organization
or your team where you get to be a leader,
I would highly recommend you to take up that position
and learn the skills necessary
to become a engineering manager.
Now, having said that,
I hope this video was really useful for you.
I really wanted to make sure that I cover all my feelings
that I went through from being AIC to a manager.
And before you take up the position,
I want you to know what you need to be aware of
as you go through so you don't feel alone.
Software career paths, career ladders, you name it.
There are so many different names for the same thing.
It is extremely important as a developer
to know what career path is right for you
and what are the different levels you can go to
as you grow in your career.
There are different titles in the industry
and every title is so confusing.
It's hard to know whether you should become
an engineering manager or a staff developer
or a technical lead.
So we will be talking about titles
and how they can be so confusing
and what are some things that you should be aware of
in tech.
So as a developer, there are typically two career paths
that you can take and there are different levels
in different companies.
Now, there is a diagram right in front of us
and I'm just showing you this diagram
just to give you an understanding of the different levels
and what these fancy titles are like
so you get a really good understanding
of what every level is expected to do
and what to know about it.
So for example, if you are a developer,
there are two paths.
One is called the individual contributor path
and the other one is the leadership track.
Now, a lot of times you will find that an IC path
has not that many levels compared to a leadership path
and that is why a lot of developers end up becoming managers
because they don't know how else to grow
unless they go into a leadership track
but it doesn't necessarily have to.
You need to find the right company and the team
where these levels are properly defined
so you can keep growing
even after you reach a specific level.
So for example, as a developer,
you can first become a entry-level developer,
then you join to an intermediate developer
and then you go to a senior developer
but whereas if you are already a senior developer
or even a high intermediate,
you can become a technical lead, a staff dev
or a engineering manager.
I have some good news.
I have been working on a course to take you
from a developer to a engineering manager
and make you a very successful engineering manager.
So if you're interested, add yourself to the wait list.
This course will cover everything that we have talked about
in this specific engineering manager series
but there's a lot more that I couldn't cover in this series
that I will cover in the course.
So please feel free to check it out
and take a look in the description below.
Now it's a very common thing
that there would be three different levels
in a developer titles.
For example, there would be an entry-level developer,
an intermediate developer and a senior developer
and a senior is supposed to take on
a lot more leadership responsibilities and tasks
compared to an intermediate or an entry-level developer
and a senior developer is also maybe asked to mentor
maybe more entry-level devs
or maybe devs more junior to them
just so that they start practicing
their leadership responsibilities as well.
So being senior doesn't just mean that you write code
but you also need to make sure that you're mentoring others
and helping improve your processes,
your team processes and so on as well.
But the minute you become a senior developer,
it does open up two paths for you.
One is that you can become a technical lead,
a staff developer.
After that, you can become a solution architect.
Now again, it completely depends in every company
that after a senior developer, you can become an architect.
And what is the difference between an architect
and a staff developer or a tech lead?
Well, an architect is mainly responsible
for architecting the different apps.
They are responsible for maybe growing the team.
An architect really takes a look
at the company's architecture holistically
and recommends the best practices
and makes sure that the architecture makes sense.
And you might even have heard the joke
that an architect does draw a lot of boxes,
which is not wrong, but an architect does a lot more
and they think about the company holistically,
the company architecture holistically technically.
Then a senior developer could also become a technical lead
or a staff dev and a tech lead would essentially
be more responsible for leading
all the technical responsibilities of a developer,
for example.
But depending on the company, after a tech lead,
you can become a principal developer
or a distinguished engineer or a fellow.
Now again, these are different levels
and the responsibilities keep growing.
But again, and the scale at which you do these things
are also different.
So for example, a distinguished engineer
or a principal developer or a fellow role
may not be available in more smaller
or medium-sized companies
because there's not a need for it.
But in bigger companies such as the Fortune 500 companies,
you will more likely see these roles
just so that people, when they reach a specific level,
they're still able to grow
and they have something to strive for
and they don't just leave the company.
So as a developer, you can take the IC path
and this is what your path will look like.
So how does a leadership path look like?
Well, let's say you are a senior dev
or a tech lead or a solution architect
and you can basically go to becoming a engineering manager.
So you might be wondering,
what's the difference between a tech lead
and an engineering manager?
Well, or a staff developer and engineering manager.
Now, tech lead and staff developer
can be completely different responsibilities and roles
and most likely they are,
but a lot of companies also have them
more or less the same.
So let's talk about the difference between a tech lead
and an engineering manager.
You can think of a tech lead
as a technical partner to an engineering manager.
An engineering manager is responsible
for the leadership of the team.
They are responsible for making sure
their proper processes, they're managing the people,
they are understanding the organization strategy
and making sure that the technical strategy is also intact.
But who is responsible for executing it?
It's the tech lead.
A tech lead is responsible
for all the technical aspect of things.
Having said that, sometimes a tech lead
is in fact the engineering manager in specific companies.
But a tech lead more or less would be responsible
for executing the technical vision of the company
and making sure that the architecture is intact
and making sure that the developers
are following the best practices.
They are participating in core reviews and so on.
Whereas the engineering manager are more towards process,
people, technical excellence,
making sure the strategy is intact.
If they do have any questions
or if they do wanna implement specific things
and give feedback,
they would necessarily work with the tech lead
and provide that feedback so that they work well together
and make sure that the technical lead is responsible for it.
But ultimately the leadership of the team
is more on the engineering manager versus the tech lead
because engineering manager is responsible
for management of people as well.
Engineering management role is more of a leadership role
whereas a tech lead is less of a leadership role.
They are still considered on the IC path
and may not be included in specific leadership meetings
because they are necessarily more tied
to the technical aspects of things.
An engineering manager would be going into those meetings,
understanding the strategy, giving feedback,
talking to stakeholders
and then partnering with tech lead to give that information
and share that information with the team.
So there's that barrier,
but sometimes technical leads
have that management experience as well.
So they are also invited to those specific meetings as well.
Tech lead are also more hands-on
compared to engineering manager
and they are responsible
for the delivery of specific features
whereas engineering managers are less hands-on
and depending on the responsibilities
and the scope of the position,
they may not even code, for example,
because there is a tech lead role.
But in a lot of companies,
there is no tech lead involved at all.
In that case, an engineering manager
does play a tech lead role
or they look for lead developers within the team
that are interested in potentially becoming tech leads
and engineering manager works with them
to become technical leads and help grow them
and improve their technical skills and leadership skills.
Because as a tech lead,
you do need to have leadership skills
and that is why it can be confusing
because there is a overlap of skills.
So what does growth look like
after you become an engineering manager?
Well, you can become a senior engineering manager
and the difference between the two
is engineering manager does lead a team of developers
but a senior engineering manager leads a team of managers.
So they have several engineering managers
reporting under them.
I have been both an engineering manager
and a senior engineering manager
and I was working towards being a director.
So a director is more or less responsible
for a specific domain.
They look at things more holistically
beyond what a senior engineering manager would do.
They're responsible for a really big domain
and making sure the senior engineering managers
have what they need
and they are taking a look at things even more holistically.
So it can happen that being a director,
you are responsible for a even bigger domain
and you have a lot more pressure
and stress because of it.
Similarly, senior director is the same idea.
A few directors are reporting into senior directors
and same thing for VP as well.
A VP overlooks the entirety of engineering
and they have a bunch of directors
and senior directors reporting into the VP
and the VP is most likely reporting into the CTO
and so on, right?
But again, like there are so many different positions
in tech, especially on the leadership track
that you can go on to if you just wanna climb the ladder.
If you don't want to, that's completely okay.
If you decide that, hey,
I just wanna be a engineering manager,
I don't wanna grow more,
I don't wanna take more responsibility,
that's completely okay
because you can just focus on that specific position.
The more you grow,
the more responsibilities you are going to have
as a developer.
So you really need to assess where you see yourself
in five years or 10 years.
You may not know now and that's completely okay.
You can try a position and figure out if you like it or not
and that is why it is my recommendation to all developers
to if there is an opportunity
of a leadership position within the team
or if there's an opportunity of getting senior,
even if you are on the IC track,
take that position and first try it out
and see if you like it and if you do like it,
then work with your manager
or potentially a promotion path for you
because you have already proven yourself for those skills.
So I really hope this makes sense.
There is a website called levels.fyi.
This is a really good website
to check what the different levels are in every company,
what salaries every position should have
and how it all works together
because this is extremely important for you
before you join a team or a company.
Look at levels.fyi and take a look
at the different positions and where you stand as well.
I highly recommend you to reach out to someone
in the company and understand
what the different positions are
so that you know where you stand
and can apply for the position accordingly.
Now, it can be very easy to say
based on all these titles that we looked at
that TechLead is supposed to do this
or staff engineer is only supposed to do that
or an engineering manager is only tied
to maybe the people management responsibilities.
But every company is so different
that you might see that there's a lot of overlap
and that is why it could lead to a lot of confusion
when you're looking for a job as a leader
or as a developer in general.
So make sure you take a look
at the different positions in the company.
And depending on the scope of the org,
like how big your company is
and the scope of the work,
there's also a staff developer involved
and potentially a principal developer
that oversees even a bigger domain or a specific domain.
So for example, if let's say you wanna make sure
that the notifications in your company
are properly taken care of,
there should be some sort of notification architecture
that's there for maybe mobile web and so on.
So how will the architecture look like?
And in that case, maybe a technical lead
maybe tied to a small team will not be able to handle that
and might not have the domain expertise.
And there needs to be someone like a principal developer
that looks at notifications for the entire company
and works with different teams
implementing those notifications.
So maybe works with the mobile team
working for mobile notification,
works with the web team for web notifications and so on
so that from a user perspective,
those notifications are the same
and users don't need to know the technical architecture
and all the behind the scenes of the code.
So again, depending on your company,
these roles can be very different
but it's important to know which company you're going for.
So accordingly, you can go for the position as well.
Now, here is my ask for you.
If you join a company and if you notice that
there are no career ladders
or expectations are not clearly defined,
please work with your manager,
please work with your HR and give feedback to them
to make sure that these do get implemented
because without these,
it's incredibly difficult for developers to grow
and otherwise one-on-ones with your manager
are just going to be things you just talk about
and there is no action being implemented.
Or if you do give this feedback
and if your manager says that you need to work on X thing
and if you do work on it,
suddenly there's a Y thing that was never talked about
which probably your manager heard from some other manager
who probably has more influence in the company.
So make sure that everything is documented
so that you know exactly what it needs
and what you need to get promoted within the company.
Now, if there's no career path
or if there is no documentation,
you can take the initiator to define it.
It doesn't matter what level you are at.
In fact, the more initiative you take
and the more support you get,
this will start to get more defined
for all developers within the company
and having a process will really help in this case.
So I really urge you to create a process
or create something in your company if it doesn't exist
and try to get an alignment from HR or your manager
to begin with just to get started.
I really hope this gives you a solid understanding
for what to look out for when you're looking for a job,
the different titles in the industry,
the different career paths and so on.
So let's take a look at this mind map
that I have created for us to walk you through exactly
what day in the life of an engineering manager looks like.
You don't necessarily need to do
all of these things in a day,
but these are some things that you need to do
and are expected to do in your role as an engineering manager.
So you can think of this mind map as a checklist
of things that you should be doing.
So if you're doing them, great.
If you're not, and if you're curious about what it takes,
become an engineering manager,
then this is a great place for you.
So let's take a look.
So take a look at this mind map.
There are several parts of this mind map,
and I don't want you to be scared
because I have basically listed down all the things
that most engineering managers are expected to do.
Now keep this in mind that every org and team
are quite different.
So you might be expected to do more things or less things
if they already have a role for that,
if they already have a position for it.
Because engineering management and project management
and a lot of it, it has a ton of overlap.
If there are roles for that,
you might not necessarily have to do those things,
but if not, then you might have to.
So I'm gonna cover a pretty robust roadmap,
but keep this in mind so that you don't get scared
that you might have to do everything in this.
This specific engineering manager roadmap
is divided into a few different pillars.
One is organization, team, people, hiring, product,
technical, communication, and personal growth.
So let's take a look at each one by one.
If you like a copy of this mind map,
you can download it for free.
Take a look at the description below if you like,
and you can have a copy of your own.
So the first thing that we are going to take a look at
is organization.
I would like you to have a top-down view of your org
so that you are able to know exactly how your role
as an engineering manager plays in the wider org
and how goals are set, how you create objectives
for your teams, and so on.
Let's start to zoom in on the org.
So there are a few things you need to keep in mind
as we discuss about the org structure.
So the first is you need to have a really solid understanding
of the vision of your org
and what the early vision looks like.
So every year, maybe towards the end of the year
for the upcoming year,
the founders or the senior leaders meet
and they discuss what the vision for the org
should look like in the next year or the next five years
and so on.
And accordingly, they decide they want to reach
to X milestone or X goals and X number,
and that's how they decide, okay,
the early vision of this specific year
or the upcoming year is going to look whatever.
Now you need to understand that vision very clearly
because then you are going to make decisions
for your team based on that,
and you will understand how your team plays a role
in that vision.
If you create goals for your teams against those goals,
then I kind of think of your team as a tiny boat
which is steering away,
which is going to slowly turn the ship away
because all these tiny teams
or all these tiny boats for the ship
are not heading in the right direction.
So your ship is going to slowly start turning away
and that's not what we want.
So have a good understanding of the org.
After you understand what the vision of your org looks like,
try to understand the business vision
and the technical vision as well.
So based on the business vision, the VP, the CTO,
or whoever that might be,
your senior leaders, senior technical leaders
are also going to create a vision for your org.
So for example, we should move away from REST APIs
and only use GraphQL,
or we should make sure that all our experiences
are fully accessible and accessibility is a priority
for every user experience that we create, which it should be.
So whatever that might be, we are going to,
you need to know that vision
so that you have a better understanding for your team.
So for example, if accessibility is part of it,
then you need to make sure that when you are creating
your roadmap for your team,
accessibility is added as the criteria
because that's also part of the vision.
The next thing is planning.
Now, based on that vision and the goals of your business,
you need to understand which goals apply to you
because there might be goals for the entire company.
Based on those goals, then you need to start planning
and planning your yearly roadmap
and then your quarterly roadmap as well.
So based on that, you're going to assess.
You wanna achieve X percent in a year.
This is our goal.
And then based on that, for every quarter,
we are going to try to meet X number, right?
Or we are going to try to hit $10 million
or whatever that might be.
Although, how many dollars does it associate to?
It's not necessarily in your control.
You are also partnering with product and design
and all the other departments as well, marketing and so on.
But you need to assess what the quarterly goals look like.
And then accordingly set ambitious goals.
Now, one framework that you can use to divide those big goals
into smaller goals is OKRs.
OKRs stand for objective key results.
And this is a framework where you can assess
how you can set a ambitious objective
and associate that to a key result
you wanna associate yourself with.
So I won't go too deep into what OKRs are,
but this should give you a good understanding
that it's the framework that is quite commonly used
while planning for the year
and while planning the roadmap.
The next thing is collaboration with HR partner.
So for your org, whenever you have to,
you also need to understand the decisions
that the org needs to make.
There's gonna be an HR.
In every HR department,
you are going to have a partner that you collaborate with.
And that partner is going to help you communicate
exactly what they need you to communicate to your team.
So make sure that you have a really strong relationship
with the HR partner
and if there is any downturn communication
or if there is any important org communication
or anything like that,
you will be able to know exactly the words to use
to communicate that to your teams
so that you make sure your team is in the best part possible
and they have all the information necessary as well.
So again, in organization,
these are a few things you need to keep in mind.
The next thing we are going to take a look at is team.
Now, team is very important for you
as an engineering manager.
There are quite a few things you need to do for your team
just to make sure that your team is in the right spot
and you have full control as a leader.
Now, make sure that you have good processes
and there is good documentation of processes.
You're iterating on those processes as well.
Again, too much process is not good.
Have a right balance for process and task management
such as who gets to do, who gets to work on what.
You need to strike a really good balance here
because you don't want to get assigned tasks to folks
that are not necessarily interested in those tasks.
So make sure you have a good understanding
of the people working on that task
and also they are motivated to work on those tasks as well
and give them full autonomy as well.
So for example, some people do create for autonomy.
So for example, if they do love autonomy
then assign them a task, talk to them about a high level goals
and let them have full control
in terms of how they want to execute it.
And you can be the sounding partner for them
and understand how they plan to implement it and so on.
But based on what the interests are,
what the strengths and weaknesses are,
accordingly assign tasks as well.
Then you need to also measure your team performance.
So for team performance, anything you want to measure,
it needs to be tracked so that you are able to measure.
So assign proper metrics and track them,
conduct weekly retrospectives.
Retrospectives are a way to reflect on how the week went,
what went well, what didn't go so well and so on.
But this is how you can measure the team performance.
For example, if your team's weekly output
is a certain number of tasks,
then make sure that you are able to maintain that momentum.
If you are not, then your project planning
might not go as planned.
So make sure that you have a good understanding
of all of that.
The next thing is project management.
Now this is something that you need to understand
that there might be another role altogether
in every company.
Now every company is so different.
So if you don't have this,
then you might have to do it on your own
or you have to gather around the developers
and assign these roles and take turns doing them.
So for project management,
you need to plan the milestones.
So for example, what are some tasks and milestones
you need to hit along the way?
Because the project can be maybe four to six months long
or one to two months long,
but what are the many milestones that you can hit on the way
just to showcase to your stakeholders
and to your team and product managers
and everyone that you are heading in the right path?
Then you need to monitor that performance.
You need to make sure that you have
good productivity practices.
So if you do know that there are certain things
that are maybe creating a lot more toil for your team,
then maybe invest some time into automating that
just because you don't want your team to be wasting time
on things that where they can be productive.
So make sure that you do invest time there.
Then is prioritization, grooming, planning.
So plan your tickets properly, plan your tasks properly,
make sure that the backlog of tickets is properly groomed
and make sure that you understand what the priorities are
based on the roadmap that you have planned as well.
But again, if the tick tasks have proper details,
then the developers will be able to work on them as well,
but obviously gather around the developers
and make sure you work on all of these.
Then is continuous improvement.
Any of those will keep changing every month.
Now, this is just a good list to have,
but you need to make sure that you keep improving,
you keep iterating with your team.
Now, for every team, different things are going to work.
Not everything is going to work for every single team.
So make sure you cater to that
so one team can differ from the other and so on.
A very important pillar of engineering management
are the people.
So this is something you need to handle
in a very delicate way
because your decisions have a huge impact on your team
and people are going to be impacted.
So make sure that you know exactly what you're doing.
Always create a plan for it.
Make sure that the decision-makers with you
are also on the same page
when you do take a look at anything to deal with people.
So because you really want to make sure you get this right.
So in people, you have to hire and onboard the people
that you work with.
Now, if you have a team of maybe two developers,
if you want to make a team,
if you want to create a team of seven developers,
and five to seven is usually the max for a team size
or a healthy max for a team size for one engineering manager.
And in that case, you need to make sure
that you're hiring the right people
and onboarding them as well.
And hiring and onboarding is a separate pillar
for this reason because there's lots to talk about it.
So we will take a look at it very soon.
Next is the happiness of the people.
It's very important that you foster a culture
of transparency, you create a psychological safety for them.
And I do have a blog post written on this topic.
If you're interested, take a look at the description,
but make sure that these things do align
with the team culture and people are happier in general
because this will add to the culture of your team.
If people are happier, people are excited to wake up
in the morning and come work for you,
then you are going to be more successful as a happy outcome.
People are going to be more productive because of that
because they are interested in making the company better.
So make sure that the happiness is really accounted for.
The next thing is feedback.
The way you gather feedback
and the way you give constructive feedback
is extremely important.
Now, feedback is so important that you really need
to make sure that you build really good frameworks
and patterns for people
because different people accept feedback differently.
Different people ask for feedback in a very different way.
So make sure that you gather feedback about them
in a proper way,
and you also give them constructive feedback as well.
Then is career growth.
Now, career growth is extremely important
in a developer's life.
The developers reporting into you really are interested
to know where they stand,
what can they do to get to the next level,
and there should be full transparency related to this.
So first, are there any career ladders set up
in the company?
And career ladders could be things like
if they are a intermediate developer,
then maybe they want to get to senior developer
or staff developer, principal developer, and so on.
Now, depending on the level you are at,
there could be different levels in every company.
So the career ladder can be completely different
in every company.
Now, if they want to take the individual contributor path,
then they can,
or if they want to take maybe a staff technical leader out,
then they can do that as well.
Now again, depending on the team that you work on,
or a staff or a technical lead
can be considered a leadership position,
or it could be considered an IC position,
an engineering manager onwards
is considered a management position or a leadership position.
So again, career ladders differ from company to company,
but make sure that you know what path they want to go on
so that you can give them opportunities accordingly.
Make sure that every developer is creating smart goals.
Smart is a framework used to create goals,
and I will link what smart means in the description below,
but they allow you to create really smart goals.
Then make sure that they do have a development plan
or a growth plan.
Again, different companies call it different things,
but a growth plan allows you to document
where they're at in their journey,
how their goals can tie to the objectives
that they're working on,
and those objectives align to the company's vision.
And this is why I kind of gave you an idea of the org vision,
the network map early vision,
and then these goals should map to that
so all the developers are working
to make the company better.
Then is the BRAG document.
A BRAG document is a document
where you document exactly all the cool things
that you have done and things that you are proud of.
So make sure every developer in your team
has a specific BRAG doc that they are proud of.
And make sure there are also promotions planned out
and mapped out as well.
So if they are already doing a good job
and meeting expectations
or even exceeding expectations in a specific level,
don't wait for them to ask you to promote them.
When you think they are ready,
start creating a plan with them
just to make sure that their career growth is on track.
So again, all of these things are very important.
Then is performance reviews.
The performance reviews are extremely important.
Now, one thing you want to really avoid,
a one mistake that you really want to avoid
is wait until the very last minute
to give a performance review to the person
or to give a feedback to the specific developer.
Anything that comes out of performance reviews,
none of it should come as a surprise to the developer.
If they're surprised, you have not done a good job
as an engineering manager.
So make sure that your performance reviews
are really on point and you already have a document
which is your growth plan that ties it all together.
Hiring the right people in your team
is going to be majority of the battle for you.
If you have really good people working for you,
then it's going to be easier for you to meet your goals,
your org goals, and as a result,
it's going to be really good
for your career growth as well.
So make sure that you hire right.
If you don't hire the right people,
it can have a serious impact
and that is why you need to make sure
you have good practices set up and as well.
So let's talk about what happens once you hire.
So once you do hire,
make sure you have really good onboarding set up for them
because your goal as an engineering manager
should be that they don't take the time to onboard,
but it doesn't take too long for them to onboard
because you have set up the right processes in place
and everything that they need to do
and need to know to get up and running quickly in their job.
So make sure there's proper documentation.
You have set up 30, 60, 90 day goals for them.
So they have some sort of a metric to head
so that they can work on those goals in their 30 days,
in their 60 days, and in their 90 days.
So make sure their first 90 days are set up for success.
I have written a ebook on your first 90 days
as an engineering leader
and everything that you need to do
to make sure your first 90 days are set up for success.
If you're interested,
take a look at the description below.
The next thing you need to make sure you do
is go through diversity and unconscious bias training.
As humans, we all have our own biases
and we need to make sure when we are hiring
that those biases don't interfere
with the way we hire people.
That's why it's important that you go through this training
before you start interviewing people
because then you're going to know
what are some of the biases that you may have
and how to make sure that those don't play a role
when you're hiring folks.
Make sure you partner with recruiting
as you're hiring as well.
Honestly, recruiters are your best friends during hiring.
If you tell them what you're looking for,
they are going to go and find people on LinkedIn
to make sure that the people are the right fit
for your specific team.
Then is interviews.
So when you're hiring,
make sure you have really good processes set up
to hire folks.
So make sure there's diverse interview participation.
There are people from your team interviewing them as well.
So they are comfortable for the new hires
that are going to join the team.
Make sure that there's a good technical challenge set up
and not something that anyone can just Google.
Then there's also a section for soft-scale assessment.
Their communication is on point
so that you know that they are a good fit for your team.
Conduct resume reviews
and you also hire for other teams as well.
So as much as it's important that you hire for your team,
you will also be expected
to interview other team members as well.
So make sure that you're really a important part of it.
You're hiring for other teams,
but you're also reviewing resumes
and making sure that you're improving
the culture of the company.
Hiring is something that you do need
to invest really good time in
because as an engineering manager,
you are going to hire folks for you,
not just for your team, but also for other teams.
So understanding their goals
and hiring the right people will really help you.
Having a diverse set of interviewers really make
for a good interview experience for the interview as well.
But again, hiring is going to be a really important part
of your role and something you should not take it lightly.
So far, we have talked a lot about different pillars
of engineering management,
but product is a pillar that is extremely important
as a engineering manager.
When you are making decisions as an engineering manager,
you will also have a product counterpart,
a design counterpart, and maybe several others too,
just to make sure that all the decisions are being made
and all the key players are in the room,
all those decisions are being made for your team.
Even though the people in your team are reporting to you,
there might be designers that are reporting
to a design manager or there might be a product person
that is reporting to a senior product manager and so on.
So you need to make sure that you are not the only one
making decisions and having a really tight collaboration
with product.
And I should also add to your design is extremely important
or any other folks that are important in decision-making.
So in product, let's make sure
that there is business alignment.
So you understand what the business is looking for.
And when product does create a strategy
as an engineering manager, you review that strategy
and really are on the same page as well.
You make sure you ideate on different ideas
that are really good for the product,
create a different strategy
and collaborate on that strategy as well.
And based on the product strategy,
make sure you also have your technical roadmap representation
and focus as well.
So if there's any technical that needs to be added
or if there's any toll that's being created
because of a specific task on your team,
then make sure that gets added and represented
in the technical roadmap as well.
A technical roadmap is always a good idea
of features that you would like to improve,
things that architecture that needs to happen
to make sure that we sustain the scale
of the product requirements.
So again, having a technical roadmap
would be really important
and something that you can initiate
and get the team involved to start creating.
Next is decision-making and critical thinking.
Always, as I mentioned earlier,
make sure that all the key decision-makers are in the team
and never say no, make sure that you use critical thinking
just to make sure that you don't just say no,
but also are able to come up with creative solutions
for the problems because again, you need that creativity
to push the art forward.
Communicating understanding of technical requirements.
Since you are a technical person in the room,
you would have to a lot of times communicate the product
and do other counterparts,
why certain tasks are taking this long,
why something needs to happen,
why the architecture needs to be prioritized
or whatever that might be,
make sure that you're communicating that
and all of you are on the same page.
And lastly, prioritizing toil and technical debt
in collaboration with product as well.
So again, if there's any toll that's been created
because of past products or past features
that you have implemented
or anything that just needs to be prioritized,
then you need to prioritize in the roadmap as well.
But again, making sure everyone is on the same page
because you're not the only decision-maker in the room.
So again, collaboration with product
is extremely important as a engineering manager.
We should call this technical excellence
because as an engineering manager,
you need to make sure that your team
is following the best practices
and everything is under control
from an architecture perspective and so on as well.
Now again, you don't need to solve
all of these problems yourself,
but get the team together to make sure
that these problems are being solved.
So for example, in the technical aspect,
there would be managing on-call
and if there's any support required
and there are off-hours of what required,
then are there best practices for it?
That you are monitoring toils,
so you have proper dashboard set up
just to make sure everything is being tracked.
If there are any incidents
that have created toll in the past,
an incident could be something,
let's say the system goes down
because of a feature that you own
or if there was a massive impact to the customers
and make sure that you have
incident management practices as well.
There's service ownership,
so anything that you create, you own.
So any of the services that you own
truly belongs to you and your team
and you truly own that.
If you have any architectural best practices
documented as well so that anyone new
that any new team collaborating with your team
can refer that document
just to make sure everything is on point.
Then there is documentation and technical analysis
being done as well for every feature that you work on
so that anytime any new feature needs to be worked on,
there's documentation
and there's a source of truth for everything,
so just make sure that this is being done
and again, you don't need to do it,
you can get your team,
you can delegate these tasks to your team to do it as well.
Then there is technical roadmap
and alignment and technical strategy
which aligns with what we talked about in product
and then there are good code quality processes
and templates created for your team
which allows your team to write better code.
So for example, there are better code review practices,
there's a no blame culture,
you are using pair programming as a way to collaborate
and get developers together and improve their skills
and so on and lastly,
you have proper practices for automatic deploys
which allows you to automate your entire process in general.
So anything that can be automated,
you can think of technical bucket or technical pillar
as a technical excellence bucket
which allows you to make sure
that the technical excellence for your team is really great
and make sure that you are following
all the best practices possible while deploying
because otherwise you're just going to create more toil
which will impact customers eventually.
So again, technical is really important.
Communication is a very important pillar
as a engineering manager.
You need to make sure that you're communicating right
and effectively, frequently with anyone
who you're working with
so that you all are on the same page
and there are no misunderstandings in your work culture.
So for example, if you're working cross-team,
then there is proper collaboration
and practices with cross-teams
that people are talking to each other,
there's proper meeting facilitation,
the teams are working well together.
Make sure that you partner with the engineering manager
or the product manager or the design manager
or whoever the leaders are of that team
so that you all are on the same page
and collaboration is seamless.
Towards the end of the day,
all the team members should be happy
that the collaboration happened
so that everyone is happier.
Then if there are proper async communication practices,
after 2020, we are in a spot
where a lot of us are in a remote culture.
So it's important that communication practices are async
and there are remote communication practices
and you don't necessarily need to get in a call
for everything, there are less meetings.
And if there are meetings
and there's a proper agenda to those meetings,
there's proper meeting facilitation.
As an engineering manager, a lot of times you might,
you will find that you are facilitating meetings
and just asking questions
and asking the right questions
to get the conversation started
so that the decisions are being made,
not every meeting will have the set of questions necessary
but just having the communication there
really helps a lot.
And that you are managing up as well.
So you have a manager
and you really need to make sure
that whatever you're working on,
you are also sharing the work that you are doing
and you're truly owning up your career.
I have written a blog post on managing up
so take a look at that
because there's a lot more to talk about
while managing up
and why it's so important for your career.
So make sure you're doing that and communicating that
because your boss, your manager should be an ally for you
and they are going to be in rooms
that probably you're not going to be
so they need to represent your work
and that's why you make sure you communicate effectively.
Then there's stakeholders.
Now, anytime you're working on something,
there is a stakeholder for it.
There are multiple stakeholders responsible
for the work that you're doing
and they are impacted, their team is impacted
with the work you're doing as well.
So make sure that there are frequent stakeholder updates.
There's communication with stakeholders.
They know how frequently you are going to communicate
and involve them early.
So if your team was working on something,
involve them early to get their feedback
because people are invested in the thing
that they give feedback on
and that they put time investment in.
So if they give feedback early,
they will be more invested
and as a result, they are going to be happier
because they can see that the team is already working on it.
So this is why communication is extremely important
with stakeholders and having a really good partnership
with them and as a manager,
communication pillar is extremely important
and if there's one thing you need to start doing
as you transition from being a developer
to an engineering manager, it's communication.
Make sure your communication is on point.
We talked a lot about communication with stakeholders,
technical excellence, product, team growth,
people growth and lots more.
But this is a very important bucket as well.
I've mentioned this in the past,
in other videos that engineering management
is just like being on an airplane
where you need to put your oxygen mask first
and then give the oxygen mask to your team.
So if you cannot breathe,
you will not be able to help your team either.
So make sure you're investing time
in your personal growth as well.
You are leveling up your skills
and there are a few ways you can level up your skills
through books and eBooks,
presentations to share learnings,
book coffee chats with other engineering leaders,
join communities, take courses and so on.
And as you already know,
I'm already working on a course
on helping you become a successful engineering manager.
If you're interested, add yourself to the wait list
and check out the course.
I'm really excited for this course
and everything that I'm covering in this specific video
and lots more is also going to be included.
And this is the part where you really need
to level up your skills
and make sure that the people on your team
don't become the experiment for your growth.
So this course is really here to help you for that.
So the next thing you need to do for your personal growth
is also document your knowledge,
share your learning with other leaders in the company,
make sure that you have a really good relationship
with them as well,
because who knows when your team
would need to work with them,
but also it's important that having a good network around you
would really help you grow in your career as well.
Then set up goals for yourself.
Again, everything that we talked about
in the growth section for your team
also applies to you as well.
Make sure that you do have a development plan
that you're working on.
You are setting up smart goals as well.
You are creating those goals and measuring as well.
Because again, as I said before,
because as an engineering manager,
it's extremely important that you measure everything.
So make sure that you are doing that for yourself
as much as you're doing that for your team as well.
And about all of this,
it's important that you take care of your mental health
and personal development as much as you care for your team.
I really hope you have a solid understanding
for what it's like to become an engineering manager
and how that differs from being a developer.
Just by comparing the day in the life
of an engineering manager,
we got to know a lot about what a developer does
and doesn't do,
and what an engineering manager does behind the scenes.
You can read all the books on the wall,
take unlimited workshops on how to become a leader,
but unless you get practical experience,
you are never going to know what leadership looks like.
So in this specific video,
we are going to talk about
how you can find opportunities as a leader,
what does a good leader even mean, or what do they do?
What are some things you should avoid doing as a leader?
My name is Ankita, and I am an educator,
and I will help you level up in your engineering career.
I have more than a decade worth of experience
leading developers, so you are in good hands.
Let's get started.
So the first thing you should do if you haven't already
is become a mentor for someone.
We all have something that we can teach others
based on our experience.
So figure out how you can become a mentor
in the company that you work at,
or even in general,
figure out who asks you a bunch of questions
and see if they're interested in potentially
being your mentee,
because being a mentor would be a really good,
valuable experience for you
to start tapping into leadership.
It is kind of like the beginner phase of leadership.
You will sort of understand
what it's like to grow someone else.
You're not directly responsible for their career
or their growth right now.
We are still invested in them.
So you will kind of get an idea
what it's like to become a leader.
Next, you should figure out
if there is a small project that you can lead.
So again, you can figure out how to work with people,
how to assign them tasks,
how to figure out what the priorities are,
and also work with your direct manager
as you are in this lead capacity.
So you will also start to see what your manager does
in certain situations being a lead.
So figure out and identify small projects
that you can work on as a leader.
Start shadowing your manager in meetings.
Figure out what decisions they make.
See what the day in the life of your manager looks like,
because that's potentially also going to be your day as well.
If you shadow your manager,
you can start taking on leadership responsibilities,
but also figure out if this is something
that you like or not.
Because if you don't like it, you don't want to do it,
that's completely okay.
But at least by this,
you would be able to figure out what even a good leader does.
You become the average of five people
you surround yourself with.
If your goal is to become a leader
or figure out how to become a leader,
what you can start doing is find out who in the company
is a leader you aspire to become.
You will learn a lot by watching them,
and also context is very important.
So you will figure out what engineering leadership
looks like in the company that you work at.
So find a mentor that can help you get there.
Discuss them your potential goals and your interests,
and that you're trying to figure out
if you want to become a leader or not.
A leader in one company might struggle in another.
That's why finding a mentor in your org
would really help you speed up that learning process.
So what makes a good leader?
If you want to become one, you need to figure out
what is the secret sauce to becoming a leader?
Now, there's never a checklist of things
that I can provide and say, yeah, check this off
and you will become a good leader.
Leadership is complex because we are dealing with people
and people are humans.
So you need to tweak your checklist
and add to it or remove items from it
depending on the org you work at.
But here are a few things that makes a good leader.
You will notice that the people that work for that leader
are incredibly happy.
Or even if they are not very happy,
they are satisfied with their job and job responsibilities.
A good leader will always know
how to build a high-performing team.
And a high-performing team is not a team of high performers.
A high-performing team is essentially a team
that collaborates effectively,
knows how to give feedback to each other,
they ship fast, they iterate, and they move on.
A good leader will know how to create
a high-performing team out of any situation.
A good leader is not just growing the people on their team,
but they are also driving business results,
which are very, very important.
You can think of this analogy
where you can imagine a duck swimming in a pond.
When you look at that duck, the duck seems really calm
and everything is going okay.
But underwater, you will notice that the duck
is working really hard to make sure that they seem calm
on the surface level.
And that's exactly what a good leader would look like.
You will not notice that there's a lot of work
that's going on in the background
because they're doing such a good job shielding the team
from all the chaos and pressure that's happening in the org.
So a good leader will definitely be doing that.
A good leader will know exactly how to grow people
at different skill levels.
And if they don't know, then they're going to ask others
for help and figure out how you can grow in your team.
They are never going to give you the answers.
They're always going to coach you and question you
so that you can come to those answers yourself.
And it always creates that light bulb moment for you.
A good leader will not give you the answers
because they know that in the future,
you're going to come back to them with the same question.
But if they ask you, then you will come
to that answer yourself
and you don't need to ask them in the future.
And that's what a good leader does.
Communication is extremely important as a leader
and a good leader will always communicate effectively,
thoughtfully and will prepare the communication
before any major event.
So for example, there might be different types
of communication.
There could be one-on-one communication
with the direct reports or people they didn't work with
or they could be org-wide communication
or big channel communication.
And a good leader will always thoughtfully prepare
what communication looks like.
This communication can literally make or break a company.
It can create chaos and it will create uncertainty
and you don't really want that.
So if you want to be a good leader,
you need to make sure that you're communicating
thoughtfully and effectively.
A good strategy for this is always create a document
and write down everything that you want to say
and review it and tweak it and use your words wisely
and then get other leaders to review the document as well
before sharing it in a channel
because the impact of that could be huge.
And this way you are aligned on the communication.
So a good leader will always have
really good communication strategies.
I have a video coming out on how to effectively communicate
that you should check out.
A good leader will always create psychological safety.
Now, psychological safety means that you can make mistakes
as a developer or as a member of the team
and you won't be punished for it.
There are no bad consequences for it.
As a developer, you are going to make a lot of mistakes.
So imagine if your manager or your leader
doesn't create a psychologically safe place
to make mistakes, then you are going to have a ton of bugs
and you're always going to hide your mistakes.
And if you want to be a good leader,
you should never do that.
So a good leader will always create
a psychologically safe place for you to make mistakes
and won't punish you for it.
Instead, figure out a way to avoid those same mistakes
in the future and create a process for it.
As a good leader, you must always praise publicly
and give feedback privately.
So this is a perfect example
wherein if you want to create a psychologically safe place,
never bash anyone publicly
because you're going to create that fear
for everyone else on your team
and you really don't want to do that.
A good leader will create that safe space
for everyone to make mistakes.
As a good leader, you always want your people
to grow and level up.
If they are stagnated, if they're not growing,
then what's the point?
You need to make sure that the people on your team
are growing and this will really make you a good leader
because you are helping them grow.
You're giving them feedback,
you are creating a development plan for them,
you're really figuring out the gaps they have
and helping them get to the goal
where they want to get to,
or you're helping them level up.
So really you need to make sure
that the people on your team are growing
as a really good leader.
You don't need to problem solve each and everything
as you did as a developer.
Now you need to handle problems on a case by case basis
because these problems are often problems with people.
So a good leader will know exactly
how to handle a specific difficult situation.
You never want to run away
from difficult situations as a leader
and you should almost be comfortable dealing with it.
It can be hard at first, but the more you do it,
the better it get, but handle with care
and handle with thoughtfulness
and it will always come across as genuine.
So as a leader, you always want to analyze things
on a case by case basis
and figure out problems or brainstorm problems together.
You might have a lot of control as a leader
and a lot of power as a leader,
but you still want people to come work for you.
And if you act like a boss and not as a leader,
then you will not have those people coming to work for you.
And you really don't want to do that
because you will not have a team.
So really make sure that you don't act like a boss,
but you start being a leader, start acting like a leader.
And based on some of the things I talked about,
because if you start being a boss,
then you're commanding
and people don't like to work for bosses.
So start being a good leader.
You need to lead by example as a leader.
You need to have a positive influence on others.
By growing other people,
you are going to grow yourself as well
and you're going to level up your skills as well.
Now, if you want people to follow you
and if you really need to walk the talk,
if you want people to follow the same guidelines
and rules that you have set for them.
So for example, if you don't want people to work late,
then don't work late as well.
If you don't want people to DM each other
or message in channels after work hours,
then don't message in work channels or be online
or show them that you are online after work.
Because again, people are just going to follow you
because you're the leader.
So whether you like it or not,
the behaviors that you adopt as a leader
are something that is going to be easily trickled down
to all your team members.
Because as a lead, you're setting the culture of your team.
So really you need to make sure
that you're leading by example.
When people say that they love or hate the company
they work for, you can be 90% confident
that they're talking about their manager
because a manager can really make or break someone's career.
So you really need to make sure
that you are being a good leader
and setting a good example for them.
I have mentioned a million different things
for what makes a good leader
and I can say a million more things more.
But again, as I mentioned at the beginning of this video,
you really need to make sure
that you are gaining that practical experience,
finding those opportunities for yourself
in order to hopefully become a leader in the future.
Hard skills get you hired,
but soft skills get you promoted.
If you had to pick one soft skill
that you truly need to master,
then it has to be communication.
After leading 100 plus developers and leaders,
I can assure you that folks that knew how to communicate,
grew quickly, got promoted
and truly created that impact that lasted for years.
If you are interested in leveling up
and getting promoted, then keep watching.
In this video, I'm going to share a four step,
simple formula for you to create a communication strategy
that you can apply in any type of meeting.
So let's get started.
So the first step in this formula
is identifying who you're communicating with.
Knowing who you're going to communicate with
is going to be a game changer for you.
You know why?
Because after you know who they are,
you can share more or less context in that meeting.
Before you get into that meeting,
figure out who's going to attend the meeting,
what their roles are, what do they care about,
what their objectives are,
and how do they tie into the context of the meeting
and why were they invited to begin with.
Knowing that is going to be huge for you
because then you can accordingly decide
whether you should provide more context,
whether you should ask them more questions
or how they're going to help your team.
This is going to make you look more confident
because you are, because you have prepped for that meeting.
So identifying who you're going to communicate with
is going to be a game changer.
Unfortunately, 90% of the folks don't know
which meeting they're getting into.
They wait for the calendar tool to notify them
five minutes before the meeting,
and then they decide to go into that meeting,
not knowing the purpose of the meeting,
who's attending the meeting,
and then that completely slows down the meeting.
So in order to craft a really good communication strategy,
you need to do the opposite of that.
You need to identify who you're talking to
so you know how to best position yourself.
The second part of the formula is to focus on the outcome
that you would like to get to.
Now, hold on a second and let's take a step back here.
Focusing on the outcome is so important.
If you know what you want to get out of that meeting
before you even get into it,
or what you want to get out of that discussion,
then you can basically backtrack and figure out exactly
what questions you want to ask
and how you want to position that meeting.
A lot of times we get too invested in the solutions
or we are too passionate about the problem
that we figured out what exactly
we want to get out of the discussion with anyone.
So if you figure out what exact outcome you want to get to,
then you can backtrack and craft steps
for how you want to get to that outcome.
If you get into the meeting
and you realize that this meeting is not productive
and you will not get closer to the outcome,
in fact, you are getting derailed
by a completely different conversation,
then backtrack and figure out what your outcome is
and remind your team of that outcome.
So for example, if you get into a heated discussion
on architectural decision with another teammate,
instead of getting too heated up,
try to figure out what is the outcome
you would like to get to based on your discussion.
Now the outcome is that you need to agree upon
a common solution that works for your team
and for the business and for your company, right?
That is the outcome.
Then you shouldn't get too hung up on having opinions
that are not supporting that specific outcome.
So again, if you do that and backtrack it,
that will really help you understand
where you would like to get to.
Now, whatever strategy that we are discussing right now,
the four-step formula along with examples,
if you'd like a template for it,
then take a look in the description below
and download the template for free.
Now, the third part of the formula is what impact
you would like to create from this specific meeting.
Now, in order to make sure that you're creating impact
as part of every meeting,
you need to create a well-structured meeting.
So for example, before you even get to the meeting,
make sure that every meeting has a clear agenda
and whatever outcome that we have just talked about
is also documented in that specific meeting.
So people are aware what to discuss upon.
If the meeting gets derailed,
make sure that people discuss the main topic
of that specific meeting and discussion.
Engage participants in the meeting.
For example, you know that you need marketing's input,
or if you need a specific developer's input in that meeting,
make sure that you get asked that input
and make it a engaging meeting
so that it's not just you who's making the decision,
but it's the entire team or the entire group
that's invited to the meeting,
really thinking out loud and giving that opinion.
Because again, in order to make sure that you level up
and get promoted and really come across
as a confident communicator,
you really don't wanna do this on your own.
You really wanna bring the entire group together
to do this together.
And manage time effectively.
Time is very important.
If you make sure that the meeting starts on time
and ends on time,
that is going to be really, really important for everyone
because again, time is energy.
The more time you spend on something,
the more energy you're going to spend on something.
So you really wanna make sure
that you are managing the meeting right
and making sure that it starts on time and ends on time.
If you are getting into a meeting or a discussion,
you need to think about what should people remember
about you as they walk away from that meeting.
So for example,
if you're really trying to create a brand around GraphQL
and you really want people to remember
that you are a GraphQL expert
or you really know a lot about GraphQL,
then before you get into that meeting,
prep for that meeting and really note down
what are the different types of questions
that are going to be asked as part of that discussion
and answer them and help the team.
Even if you don't know the answer, that's completely okay.
You can take away those questions
and really figure out how to help the team later on.
But again, make sure that you know what impact
you would like to create as part of that meeting.
The minute you start thinking about that,
you're going to behave a bit differently than you do.
You're going to start being more active in the meeting.
You're going to be an important part of the meeting,
which is really, really important.
If you are interested in knowing how to be a great leader
and in fact, how to be a badass one,
then check out another video that I have created.
The fourth step in the formula is
what are some of the actions that you can create
as part of this specific discussion?
Towards the end of every meeting
or towards the end of every discussion,
there are a list of action items that you can take away
that you can work on.
You can remind the group of that.
You can remind the team of that,
but you can also take away some of those action items
and make sure that they are delivered.
Once they are done,
let the team know in the channels that you're part of,
where all your other team members are,
because again, that's going to make you look
a lot more confident and you are communicating seamlessly.
What action items can you take
from that specific discussion or meeting?
Make sure that it's documented somewhere
so that everyone knows what you have discussed.
There's no room for miscommunication and misunderstanding
because everything is documented.
Make sure that you get alignment from everyone else
by repeating the goal of the meeting
and the action items that came out of that meeting
because you are going to look more confident and prepared
and you know exactly everyone is aligned
on that specific topic.
And overall, just be helpful in making sure
that discussion gets to the specific outcome
that you would like to get to.
The key thing here is that throughout this specific video
and in this specific formula,
I have talked about all the different ways
you can communicate how you need to be prepared
for the meeting, how you need to make sure
that you're answering questions,
how you can share context and so on.
And all of these things,
if you keep repeating over and over,
you are going to come across as really confident
because you are someone who is prepared for the meeting.
You know exactly what the discussion is about
so you know that you have that additional leverage
over others in that specific meeting.
This lesson, we are going to talk about some frameworks
that we can use to learn how to give feedback effectively
and the importance of feedback overall.
Now, feedback is so personal and unique
that you would need to keep evolving your framework.
You will learn that the feedback you may give to one person
is completely different to the feedback
you share with someone else.
So feedback is so personal and so unique
that you need to keep evolving it.
And we have talked about the buddy pattern
in the anti-patterns lesson
and you wanna be liked and loved so badly
that you will never give a single piece
of negative feedback.
And we talked about this as a buddy pattern
in the anti-patterns lesson of engineering leadership.
You wanna be liked, we wanna be loved
because we are humans after all
and we never wanna do the hard things of giving feedback.
But this behavior is not going to create
any positive team culture.
In fact, it's going to do the opposite of that.
You're going to slow down, you're learning,
you're going to slow down your team
because you're in danger,
because this might lead to more potential behavior
which might be worse for your team.
You really need to make sure that you give feedback.
And feedback is the best gift you can give it to someone.
Most leaders are scared to give feedback
because they think that their colleague
might not take them in the right way.
The colleague might get defensive,
get mad at you for sharing feedback,
but it is the best gift you can give it to someone.
Negative feedback is difficult.
You may find excuses to not do it or postpone it,
but keep this in mind,
that if you're not sharing this feedback,
you give them zero chance of improvement
and that is not fair to them.
So giving negative feedback is extremely important.
And the problem is never the person themselves,
it's the behavior that they're exhibiting.
And if you know this about feedback,
that it's not the person, it's not personal,
it's the behavior that we need to rectify,
suddenly a lot of things change when you're giving feedback.
And if you combine that with our initial fight
or flight response, then it gets worse.
You're likely to experience a social threat
when facing people of higher status,
feeling or sense of uncertainty,
or feeling disconnected,
which is something that is unfair.
Now, if you combine that with like fire or flight response,
it's no wonder feedback is not part of our high priority list
because whenever we receive feedback,
we get really defensive.
And that's not what we want, but that's what happens.
And that's why feedback is difficult to receive and to give.
But one hot tip is that you don't give feedback
or take any action that will impact others
if you don't have the time to address the feedback,
or if you don't have time to listen to their story,
that is if you're in a rush.
Because if you're in a rush to give someone the feedback,
it's a sign that you have failed them
before you even got started with them.
It's best to hold off until you have something concrete
or positive to say,
and have more something constructive to say.
Because when you're feeling like you have to give someone
feedback and you cannot wait until tomorrow,
it's a sign that maybe there's a problem with you,
you are insecure or something that has gone wrong with you,
or they had a really massive impact on you
with the behavior that they exhibited.
So make sure that you take the time, take the day off,
don't stress too much, and after you give it some time,
collect your thoughts and give them feedback.
And reflect when you felt grateful
after receiving feedback.
So think of a time when someone gave you feedback
that actually made you feel good,
even though it was constructive feedback.
How did they convey their message?
Why did you value that feedback?
How did that make you feel?
Think of that as you start to craft and learn
to give feedback more frequently to your team.
And we have a framework.
This is one of my favorite frameworks to use,
which is SBI framework with the twist.
Now we can divide this framework into three parts.
Situation, behavior impact, and outcomes.
Now, situation as in, what was the situation that happened
where you felt the need to give feedback?
What was the situation like?
Were you in meetings?
Did someone say something?
What was the situation?
What is the behavior that you would like to change?
What behavior impacted the team or impacted you
or someone else on your team?
You wanna be very careful of that.
For example, if they're interrupting in meetings,
then you need them not to do that.
So let them know the behavior needs to change
where they need to stop interrupting others
and make others feel excluded.
And impact is that your other team members felt excluded
and that is the impact from their behavior, right?
And the situation was that you were in a team meeting,
discussing ideas and thoughts,
and someone came up really strongly
and kept interrupting everyone else in the meeting.
That's not how you want, right?
And that's the essence of SBI framework.
But I like to add a twist and say,
let's also focus on the outcome
because then that helps you with feedback in general.
What is the outcome you would like from that conversation
when you're giving feedback?
Is the outcome that you would want their behavior to change,
you don't want them to interrupt others in the meeting,
then let them know that.
So the outcome here, it's not just you and me, right?
Let's start to figure out
what is that behavior that we need to change
because it's not them, it's the behavior, right?
And you can also use this infographic here
to use SBI framework with the twist
so that you can easily reference it in the future
when you're giving feedback.
So let's say you have a situation,
let's take a look at an example.
You have a team member that is very senior in the org
and is not mentoring junior devs
and not really prioritizing them.
What is something that you need to do?
Well, your first instinct is going to be
that this is not okay.
This in this case would be
that you would want this behavior to stop or change
and that's going to be your first instinct.
But the second is going to be that they're mean
and they're rude,
that they're constantly talking over people.
This is not making the team feel good
and the team is not speaking up because of that.
And that is the impact.
So let's try giving this feedback using this framework.
And these are the list of questions that I have
in the workbook that you can use
to craft this specific feedback.
That is, what is the outcome?
What is the context?
What is the situation?
What behavior needs to change?
Why do you think this happened?
And what was the impact that it had on the team?
You can use these questions
to craft a really good feedback message.
So workbook time.
You want to collectively craft a feedback message
using a SBI model with a twist
and make sure that you give it a shot.
So what are some important things
to note about feedback, right?
You always want to be open to hearing
their side of the story, their feedback, right?
Because as much as you are open to sharing yours,
they also have a side to it,
which is very important.
So maybe you don't have context
to new things that could have happened
that maybe they did not let anyone else talk
because you were in a client meeting
and you knew a backstory
which would significantly impact the project.
There could be many different reasons.
And then suddenly you start feeling like,
oh, that's why they kept interrupting others.
And even though that's not okay,
and they should never do that,
there was a better way to handle it.
And that feedback can change based on that.
And lastly, document the action items.
What are the takeaways for them?
And ask them what the action items were from this
so that you can make sure that there's alignment.
The answers should always align to what you talked about,
but, and it shouldn't be perfect,
but it should have the essence of what you are looking for.
There, this is Ankita.
Thank you so much for checking out this course
on engineering leadership.
I really hope you like it if you do.
And if you have any questions,
please let me know in the comments below.
But if you want to continue learning further
and if you're serious or even curious
about becoming an engineering leader or a manager,
then you can also check out this course
that have created call as developer to leader.
It will take you from being a developer
wherever you are at
to becoming a successful engineering leader.
And it will teach you how to lead a team,
how to grow a team, how to hire right,
how to create a engineering vision,
how to create a technical roadmap
and how to deliver feedback,
how to receive feedback
and lots more that I couldn't necessarily cover
in this specific course.
So I really hope you check it out.
And if you do, then you can use the code,
free code cam for 25% off additionally as well.
So I really hope you check it out.
Once again, thank you so much for watching
and I hope you have a wonderful day.
Bye for now.